uh my last play was actually he was
tatted you know neck to toe it doesn't
really look like
me when I build a my player having a
lighter weight allows your player to be
faster which is perfect for the way I
like to play on 2K the first thing I do
is put my three at a Max I think speed
is important you want to be quick as a
guard vertical jump stamina stamina
looks good ball handle upgrade that
there's a bunch of cool badges every
year um this year the new one the float
badge is one I'm looking to get I mean
that's the way I love to play in real
life I shoot a lot of floaters in that
mid-range area so I'm going to look to
get that badge as quickly as I
can obviously this is the first place
I'd come to shop growing up as a kid you
know I wanted to be a Nike athlete I
always wore um Nike shoes Nike clothes
offc Court Nikes I wear a lot of Air
Forces um on the court I'd say Kobe is
my big one I've always played in Kobe
Kobe sixes are my favorite Kobe I feel
like for me it's the most
comfortable it's very special for me to
see my NBL Adelaide Jersey in 2K I think
basketball in Australia has really grown
in terms of popularity it's exciting
because a lot of kids in Australia that
are play this game and they see that the
NBL has made its way into NBA 2K and on
a global stage is very
special I think Fashion's becoming a big
part of the NBA the tunnel in my second
year um I lean more into it and um
started dressing up and taking time to
pick out
outfits my team loves to play 2K we got
a lot of guys that um play the game it's
a lot of fun it gets competitive I think
2K is you know brings out the
competitive age in
everybody I started playing 2K 10 years
ago 2K uh definitely helped my interest
with basketball I already loved the game
but um being able to play with you know
people that you looked up to growing up
it was
awesome the graphics get better every
year the inclusion of uh of pro play
this year I think it's evident you know
in the in the new 2k 24 with how guys
are moving around on the
floor I spent a lot of time running
around the city checking out different
things seeing what's new this season
they have of getting in the city where
you have to track down me for a quest
and that's a really special thing
getting to you know not only see myself
in the game but um hear myself speak and
um and be one of the quests that uh that
the 2K players have to complete and
that's a really special feeling when
you're playing you just got to Plate
don't think don't beat yourself up my
friends back home love playing as me and
as and as my team and they're definitely
you know a lot more excited about
it they love 2K you know the same way I
do and usually I'm the one in the park
you know getting carried by them but
it's a lot of fun to be able to get on
the mic and and talk with those guys and
get in the park with them for a couple
hours and obviously it's different with
the time differences but we try as much
as we can to play together my best
friend uh Liam Conway he was the big on
the team and and he used to carry us so
shout out to him cuz he gone me through
it a lot of late nights and save me a
lot of anger and broken
controllers yeah that was um that that
was a nightmare game for me
[Music]
personally